on va parler de l'examen au Sénat du
projet de loi immigration et il y avait
un article qui suscitait détenenstions
des divergences et ça y est la fumée
blanche est sortie hier soir Steve et il
sera examiné aujourd'hui ENCI ouais
c'est l'article qui tend un peu tout le
monde he je vais quand même vous
rappelez ce qui est l'article 3 parce
que je vous aime bien Orian l'article 3
prévoit la délivrance de plein droit
d'une carte de séjour temporaire un
étranger qui travaille pendant au moins
8 mois dans un secteur en tension vous
l'avez dit le blocage a duré de longues
semaines de long jour fumée blanche
aperçu hier soir dans la soirée on va
voir ce communiqué publié par Bruno
retaillot le chef du groupe LR après
discussion les LR se sont entendus avec
les centristes d'herv Marseille la
majorité sénatoriale s'accorde pour
supprimer les articles 3 et 4 du projet
de loi sur l'immigration et pour durcir
les conditions d'application de la
circulaire Vals article 4 porte sur la
procédure d'asile je vais expliquer ce
que c'est que la circulaire Vals parce
que c'est tout le monde ne sait pas
forcment c'est texte de 2012 qui permet
aux étrangers en situation irrégulière
qui sont en France depuis au moins 5 ans
et qui travaillent de de demander leur
régularisation il faut avoir travaillé
au moins 8 mois sur les deux dernières
années pour obtenir un titre l'accord LR
centrist prévoit de durcir les
conditions de régularisation de ces 100
papiers l'accord demande aussi de
laisser la main au préfet ce sera à eux
de dire si oui ou non l'étranger en
question remplit et bien les critères de
régularisation parmi ces critères la
majorité sénatoriale veut inclure
notamment l'inté tion ou non de
l'individu dans la société et son
adhésion ou non aux valeurs de la
République affaire à suivre l'article
devrait être examiné dans la soirée et
on suivra évidemment ça alors c'est
l'article qui bloquait un peu le texte
et qui faisait se poser la question de
savoir si un compromis allait être
trouver là ça y est c'est c'est une
victoire politique des républicains bah
on verra on verra ce que ce que dira
aussi l'Assemblée nationale bon c'est
que l'article 3 il posait problème au
républicains qui on faisait une sorte de
ligne rouge évidemment à ne pas dépassé
mais pardonnez-moi se réfugier derrière
la circulaire Vals d Vals de 2012 c'est
aussi à mon sens un sujet pour deux
raisons la première raison c'est que il
y avait une certaine hypocrisie autour
de la circulaire Vals puisque il fallait
justifier comme vous l'avez rappelé d'un
certain nombre de mois travailler pour
pouvoir son dossier instruit très long
administratif et cetera et infin c'était
le préfet qui décidait mais en réalité
pourquoi c'est complètement on marche un
peu sur la tête parce que normalement
quand vous êtes un travailleur illégal
vous n'avez pas le droit de travailler
donc justifier de mois ou d'années de
travail alors que vous n'avez pas le
droit de travailler en amont c'est bon
voilà donc je pense pas que la
circulaire Vals résoudra grand-chose bon
il y a un coup de de de monton politique
DLR moi pour moi le vrai sujet il reste
sur la table c'est-à-dire que il y a une
partie du patronat qui a besoin pour des
métiers en tension et qu' le fait
d'avoir des travailleurs qui parfois on
des feuilles de paye qui n'ont droit à
rien mais qui sont illégaux mais la
vraie question c'est comment fait-on
pour lutter contre l'immigration
illégale pardonnez-moi parce que on va
attendre les conclusions du rapport
Claudé vin Patrick stéphanini qui
conclurait d'après ce que j'ai cru
comprendre à ce que ça ne crée pas
d'appel d'air ni sur l'aide médicale
d'État et CEA mais si on régularise
régulièrement parce que tous les métiers
sont un jour en tension tous les métiers
sont un jour en tension il y aura pas
que la restauration l'hôtellerie bon
donc c'est c'est quand même sujet
important et puis aussi je je je je le
dis c'est un titre de séjour temporaire
mais attendez un titre de séjour
temporaire à partir de quel moment on
décidera que le secteur n'est plus en
tension de mœuvre et des gens qui
auraient qui se seraient marié qui aurit
eu des enfants scolarisés vous leur
dites je suspends Votre titre de séjour
temporaire non tout ça donc ça ça
débloque peut-être le vote du texte mais
ça résout pas le problème la politique
c'est de la politique Catherine oui je
je partage tout à fait votre analyse
c'est de la politique là il s'agit pour
les LR de marquer et c'est bien cela qu'
a dire auillot hier soir nous avons
gagné ce ne sera pas le projet de loi du
gouvernement qui sera voté qui qui va
passer donc du Sénat à l'Assemblée
nationale le l'accord qui a été trouvé
avec les centriste était un accord en
fait tout à fait enfin qui change pas
grand-chose à l'équilibre puisque comme
vous l'avez rappelé en effet au dernier
en dernière instance c'était bien les
préfets qui prenaient la décision avant
ou après l'article 3 donc il y a pas de
grande modifications il y a un affichage
qui a été choisi par l'lr qui est
compliqué parce que c'est un affichage
comme vous l'avez dit qui contrevient à
la demande même du patronat qui est en
difficulté pour pouvoir recruter dans un
certain nombre de métiers de métiers
dans lesquels le on ne trouve pas de
main d'œuvre sur le territoire national
probablement et essentiellement parce
que cette main-dœuvre est trop mal payée
trop mal considérer des conditions de
travail trop difficiles et donc on ne
trouve pas et donc on fait appel à une
main- d'œuvre immigrée et par et
personne ne se pose la question de de
reconsidérer ses conditions de travail
ce qui avait pourtant été promis au
lendemain du covid comme on s'en
souvient Emmanuel Macron avait dit qu'on
allait reconsidérer tous ces
travailleurs de la première ligne de la
première nécessité et en fait il n'en a
rien été donc on reste avec une
situation dans lequelle il y a des
métiers qui ne sont pas pourvus par les
Français soit parce qu'ils sont très peu
qualifiés très mal payé ou autre
question c'est un certain nombre de
métiers par exemple qui va à l' hôpital
c'est très bien que l'hôpital français
fonctionne aujourd'hui pour l'essentiel
avec des médecins qui ont été formés
dans d'autres pays et qui viennent et
qui sont pompés médecins infirmiers qui
viennent et qui sont pompés par l'ce que
du coup ça veut dire que cette victoire
politique àich par Bruno Rio elle
pourrait revenir en boomerang r à
l'épreuve des fait ah moi ce que je je
pense qu'il a l'épreuve des faits et
puis il y a aussi au final quelle est la
le positionnement que cherche à avoir
les LR on se souvient que la semaine
dernière ils ont pensé avoir fait un
truc formidable en en s'opposant à
l'écriture inclusive et donc en prenant
de front toutes les personnes qui se
préoccupent de comment on féminise la
langue française aujourd'hui c'est les
migrants à la semaine précédente c'était
les éoliennes et l'écologie c'estàd
qu'en fait il y a un positionnement de
la droite LR qui est de plus en plus
conservateur réactionnaire et dont on
voit bien qu'elle tourne qu'elle cherche
en fait à récupérer un électorat qui lui
a échappé du côté de l'extrême droite
moi je pense c'est un très mauvais
calcul parce que extrême droite est
suffisamment forte aujourd'hui en France
c'est soit on la contrebat sur son
terrain idéologique soit on perdra il
n'y a pas de possibilité de reconquérir
on est plus en 2007 avec un Jean-Marie
Le Pen discrédité vieillissant et cetera
aujourd'hui Marine Le Pen et le
rassemblement national sont installés
soit on les bat sur le terrain
idéologique soit on perdra or les LR
renonce pour l'instant au contraire en
boîte le pas en espérant dans cette
course à l'échalotte récupérer une
partie de leur électorat voilà je pense
que ils ils vont perdre ouis DISP alors
on é à peu près d'accord sur Madame
jusqu'à présent pour la suite je bon euh
je pense qu'il y a longtemps si vous
voulez que les mots agités conservateurs
réactionnaires ne veulent plus dire
grand-choseés mais je je vais vous dire
pourquoi je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que pendant des années et là je
fais juste une petite parenthèse pendant
des années la gauche et c'est vrai
portait le le le le le débat porter les
questions sur la table du débat national
c'était des grandes questions sociétales
que les inelligacia de gauche mettait
sur la table et ceux qui étaient en
réaction vous avez raison ceux qui
réagissaient c'était plutôt les gens de
droite donc c'était des réactionnaires
aujourd'hui et c'est l'une des raisons
pour laquelle la gauche s'est effondré
aujourd'hui ceux qui mettent les idées
sur la table sont pas les gens de gauche
ils ont moins d'idées ils ont plus
d'idées ils sont en réaction sur des
thèmes qui sont mis sur la droite qui
sont des thèmes de sécurité
d'immigration donc plutôt des thèmes de
droite et qui sont les nouveaux
réactionnaires ceux qui réagissent ce
sont les gens de gauche voyez donc on
peut on peut se traiter de conservate de
réactionnaire des réactionnaires je
pense surtout que la gauche je pense
surtout que la gauche a abandonné a
abandonné les classes moyennes Terranova
on s'en souvient la gauche a abandonné
la classe ouvrière et tout ça bah vous
le payez aujourd'hui je pense d'une
certaine manière alors vous n'êtes pas
une femme politique mais non mais vous
nêtes pas une femme politique mais je
vous entendais dire oui conservateur
réactionnaire ça je pense que tout ça ça
ça ne convient plus par rapport à la
situation dans laquelle d'accord comment
qualifierez-vous la position
systématique notamment notamment
je vous demande pas d'être LR ou pas LR
je ne suis pas LR non plus je me permets
de les qualif je me permets de les
qualifier donc comment com enfin comment
comprenez-vous le positionnement
systématique notamment au Sénat de façon
assez assez forte et homogène sous la
direction de bonorotillo comment
comprenez-vous leur position ils ont
vraiment un positionnement sur un axe
d'ailleurs Bruno rotaillo enfin je veux
dire on le connaît je veux dire il est
il vient pas d'apparaître dans le champ
politique et au-delà de saord vous avez
o vous avez o vous avez vous n'avez pas
tort c'est que les LR cherche un
positionnement politique les LR ils sont
ils étouffent dans d'espace politique
nonque non j'ai pas dit un
positionnement j'ai dit il cherche un
espace politique il cherche à à survivre
politiquement les LR ils sont dans une
situation compliquée ils ont pas
vraiment de champion pour la
présidentielle même si vquier vous voyez
bien que ils sont dans une position
alors le PS j'en parle pas mais ces
anciens partis de gouvernement sont dans
la même situation en fait au
le PS à
gaucher donc en fait chacun essaie de
trouver un espace politique et peut-être
que Monsieur rotillot ou monsieur marlex
à l'Assemblée nationale se disent bon là
on tient quelque chose sur la loi
immigration il faut pas il faut pas
canner parce que si si on laisse passer
l'article 3 en fait ça sera quoi la
différence entre les LR et d'autres
Renaissance ou horizon pas sûr qu' voilà
donc en fait il y a un problème aussi je
pense pour les LIR de survie politique
bon le PS peut-être est en commat
dépassé donc ça c'est c'est pour ça je
vous disis l'IR de l'article le 3 c'est
en fait essentiellement un enjeu de
symbole politique c'estàd qu'en vérité
l'accord qui até troué j'ai commencé par
ça mais tout à fait je vous en ai donné
acte l'accord qui a été trouvé avec les
les centristes en fait ramène dit les
choses clairement c'est pas ça l'enjeu
l'enjeu est un enjeu de différenciation
par rapport au gouvernement et en
essayant de donner un signal très proche
des propositions d'ailleurs dans celle
que j'ai oublié il y a la remise en
cause de la de l'assance maladie et le
référendum sur l'imigra
que reprend d'ailleurs à son compte le
ministre de l'intérieur alors ça c'est
pas dans le texte mais dans les mesures
qui ont été durci effectivement le le
Sénat a voté hier la suppression de
l'aide médicale d'État qui a remplacé
par une aide médicale d'urgence donc un
panier de soins beaucoup plus restreint
il y a eu également le rétablissement du
délit de séjour irrégulier qui a été
voté hier soir quiavait supprimé
François Hollande et puis siiv le Sénat
qui a également limité le regroupement
familial oui le faut rappeler ce qu'est
aujourd'hui le regroupement familial
c'est un dispositif qui est encadré par
une directive européenne de 2003 si on
est étranger qu'on souhaite et bien
faire venir un conjoint ou des enfants
en France il faut séjourner sur le
territoire depuis au moins 18 mois avoir
des ressources stables et disposer d'un
logement dit normal il faut aussi se
conformer au principes régissant la vie
familiale en France c'est-à-dire en fait
accepter notamment la monogamie les
sénateurs ont donc Durc ce dispositif
lors des débats la durée de séjour
passerait de 18 à 24 mois les conditions
de our ne doivent plus seulement être
stables elles doivent désormais aussi
être régulières le Sénat demande enfin à
ce que le demandeur dispose d'une
assurance maladie pour lui et pour sa
famille voilà est-ce que c'est
l'illustration du durcissement des
républicains qui disent que ce texte
doit envoyer un signal un signal de
fermeté mais oui c'est évidemment que
c'est un signal de durcissement personne
peut le contester vous avez raison c'est
mais encore une
fois le sujet au-delà des métiers en
tenstion au-delà de
l'aide
médical
d'État l'aide médicale d'État c'est
évidemment la possibilité je le rappelle
he pour des travailleurs qui sont
illégaux de bénéficier de soins médicaux
bon ça me paraît logique pour au moins
de raisons pour eux pour eux et puis
aussi pour nous parce que si c'est c'est
ces immigrés illégaux viennent en France
et apporte des épidémies bon donc mais
il faut quand même constater que ça
explose alors vous allez me dire 1
milliard 4 sur 350 milliards de budget
de la SCU c'est pas grand-chose oui
parce que le problème le problème de
fond et j'y reviens bon encore une fois
il y a des terrains communs mais le
problème de fond c'est comment lutte-on
quand même contre l'immigration illégale
est-ce que vous savez je me souviens de
François miteran ou George Marchet à
leur époque qui incarna la gauche qui
qui qui ont eu des discours sur
l'immigration illégale et je pense que
George Marchet cher madame ou François
mitteran n'était ni conservateur ni
réactionnaire ou alors j'ai perd mon
latin regardez écoutez les déclarations
à l'époque déjà on se disait mais
comment c'est anormal disait François
miteran il faut il faut raccompagner ces
gens alors les mots changai il faut
raccompagner ces gens chez eux bon voilà
et puis le réchauffement ou le
changement climatique va faire aussi que
vous allez avoir de de nouvelles
migration parce qu'il y a des gens qui
vont voir leur pays une partie de leur
pays leur territoire inondé et va bien
falloir qu'il migrent ailleurs B il y a
des solutions les coopérations sur place
mais en tout cas oui lutter contre
l'immigration illégale est-ce que c'est
réactionnaires est-ce que c'est être un
méchant extrémiste de droite que de dire
ça je je ne pense pas je crois que ça
n'a rien à voir avec la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale je crois encore
une fois que c'est du symbole politique
malheureusement qui va se faire au
détriment de personne c'estd que c'est
des gens qui contre l'imigration
illégale ou pas Madame oui oui monsieur
mais mais ce que ce qui est en train
d'être fait est absolument inhumain et
et c'est fait uniquement pour des
raisons idéologiques et politiques de
positionnement parce que vous avez
convenu que ça ne représente pas
grandchose c'est
0,0,4 % des dépenses de santé l'aide
médicale d'État qui va transformer en
aide médicale d'urgence donc on sera pas
va passer à
0,0 les dépenses augmentent sans arrêt
quand même toutes les dépenses de santé
augmentent passer un scander aujourd'hui
c'est devenu une banalité c'était pas du
tout une banalité il y a 40 ans donc
toutes les dépenses de santé augmentent
donc celle-ci aussi au titre au titre
des soins donc ça c'est la première
chose c'est que ça sur le plan
économique ça ne changera rien aux
dépenses de santé sur le plan de
soi-disant l'appel d'air mais d'abord
tous les pays EUR euré ont ce type de
protection ce n'est pas spécifique à la
France le le le dispositif le périmètre
les conditions peuvent varier mais et
quand on est un immigré qui prend des
risques sur sa propre existence pour
venir en France on fait pas on n'a pas
un guide du touriste de l'immigration
avec des cases où on regarde quelles
sont les meilleures conditions les moins
bonnes conditions d'ailleurs la France
ne fait pas partie des pays qui sont les
plus recherchés par ceux qui arrivent de
façon illégale dans le territoire de
Schengen donc ce que l'on est en train
de faire ça ne règlera rien à la
question de l'arrivée des d'étrangers en
situation illégale par contre ça donne
encore une fois le symbole l'idée queon
est en train de faire quelque chose on
est en train de faire quelque chose non
monsieur il faut faire des choses des
choses
util pe pas il faut accueillir toute
la non je suis Pau bordeur donc non ce
n'est pas mon point de vue ce que je
vous dis c'est qu'en revanche le faire
en faisant en faisant payer à des
pauvres gens qui vont avoir plus de
difficultés à ple de pauvres gens en
France aussi
hein et d'ailleurs je pense à eux et
d'ailleurs je pense à eux et que je
pense que toute cette politique qui est
dégrade le service public est
extrêmement dommageable mais ça pourrait
on se reverra peut-être à d'autres
occasions ça sera pas le sujet
aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui ce que je
sais c'est que pour faire du symbolique
on est en train de rendre la vie plus
difficile à des gens qui l'ont déjà
beaucoup c'est des gens qui travaillent
qui payent des cotisations qui payent
des impôts mais qui ont du mal à avoir
leur leurs papiers de façon régulière et
qui donc vivent dans la peur et et qui
peivent avoir encore plus de difficultés
à se soigner tout ça c'est uniquement
pour faire de l'agitation essayer de
faire gagner 0,3 % à leurenvoquer dans
le prochain sondage un dernier mot HC
Revel après on va parler de la marche
contre l'antisémitisme bah un dernier
mot par exemple on pourrait parler alors
bon il y a ce sujet qui est sur la table
mais vous avez compris qu'on éétait pas
tout à fait
d'accord bon voilà bon moi j'ai pas
l'impression d'être un militant
politique j'ai l'impression d'être
plutôt équilibré mais oui il y a
d'autres sujets aussi voyez alors pas
mis sur la table mais cette grande
marche contre l'antisémime suite oui ben
oui parce que j'aimerais avoir votre
point de vue on parler on va parler il
faut pas y aller on y on y va on va
faire le point puisque hier voilà c'est
parfait
vous c'est parfait vous êtes parfait
puisqueier soir Gérard LCH et brun PIV
ont donc annoncé une initiative
politique pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme cette marche annoncé
dimanche oui appel pour la République et
contre antisémitisme annonce conjointe
de la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale yelbron pivé et du président
donc du Sénat Gérard Larcher l'appel a
été lancé dans une tribune publiée dans
Le Figaro aujourd'hui on va voir cette
tribune depuis l'attaque terroriste
perpétrée en Israël par le Hamas le 7
octobre dernier un massacre due nign
jamais égalé depuis la Choa qui a causé
la mort de 40 de nos compatriotes les
actes antisémites se multiplient
dangereusement dans notre pays plus
qu'un sursaut plus que des mots une
mobilisation générale est indispensable
la marche la marche aura donc lieu ce
dimanche 15h elle partira de l'Assemblée
nationale et ira jusqu'au Sénat alors
est-ce que cet appel a été entendu par
les partis politiques quelles sont les
réactions c'est oui pour la majorité
présidentielle c'est oui pour la droite
c'est oui pour l'extrême droite les LR
participeront le RN aussi on va voir ce
tweet de Jordan Bardella nous répondront
présents et ce matin Marine Le Pen a
lancé un appel à ses électeurs on va
l'écouter l'ensemble de nos élus il
seront et j'appelle d'ailleurs
l'ensemble de nos adhérents et de nos
élè cteur à venir se joindre à cette
marche à cette manifestation il est
temps que le peuple français je crois
dans sa diversité exprime son rejet
absolument total de l'augmentation
spectaculaire des actes visibles en fait
d'antisémitisme à gauche les voix sont
un peu plus discordantes on va voir ce
tweet de Jean-Luc Mélenchon que vous
évoqueiez après l'annonce de gerérard
arché de yel brun pivé les il parle des
amis du soutien inconditionnel au
massacre ont leur rendez-vous il évoque
également un prétexte d'antisémitisme
dans son tweet les insoumis disent
réserver leur réponse en raison de la
présence annoncée du rassemblement
national de son côté le Parti socialiste
y participera même s'il juge illégitime
selon ces termes la présence du
rassemblement national cuide des
communistes et bien Fabien Roussel sur
France 2 annonce ce matin qu'il ira à la
marche mais il veut faire un peu band à
part
écoutez-le je pense que le rassemblement
national au regard de son histoire n'a
pas sa place dans un tel
rassemblement risque et en tout cas pour
ma part je ne défilerai pas à ces côtés
nous trouverons les moyens je vais
rencontrer moi les autres responsables
des forces de gauche républicaines nous
défileront
peut-être un autre
endroit mais pas avec eux il y aura une
marche dimanche mais elle sera pas très
très coordonnée visiblement apparemment
des divisions notamment à gauche sur la
question de la du rassemblement national
ah bah oui oui bien sûr ça c'est c'est
évident bon le tweet de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon interroge quand même
interpelle quand même parce que autant
je comprends la position de Fabien
Roussel bon il se
dit le Front national puis le rassembl
national ont une histoire qui a été
marquée par des dérapages antisémites de
Jean-Marie Le Pen donc ne pas
défiler de manière unitaire mais un
autre endroit mais contre la même cause
qui est l'antisémitisme bon pourquoi pas
mais lire ce tweet de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
où il expque qu'il ne souhaite
pas en fait l'antisémitisme serait un
prétexte voyez les médias créent
l'antisémitisme on parlerait
trop il ne met en avant que le massacre
dont souffre le peuple palestinien en ce
moment c'est c'est c'est évident voilà
et tout commence quand même
souvenez-vous tout commence
par la France insoumise qui refuse de
qualifier le Hamas de groupe
terroriste barbare avec madame auonau
qui explique ce sont des résistants très
bien ben moi je pense que c'est
extrêmement grave ça fait peser un poids
sur la politique française qui est très
important et je vais même vous dire je
me demande dans quelle mesure en fait
euh la France insoumise n'est pas en
train de réactiver euh elle-même par les
prises d'pposition de certains de ses
leaders d'une forme d'antisémitisme dans
ce pays
Carine moi je me réjouis qu'il a une
initiative qui vienne de
l'institution je trouve très bien que
les partis j'imagine que des syndicats
des associations vont s'y rallier je
pense que c'est bien que les
institutions en tant que telles à propos
de la République prennent cette
initiative donc personnellement je m'en
réjouis et je vois aussi le problème que
pose la présence du Front national du
rassemblement national qui n'est pas
simplement un problème lié à des petites
lagague de Jean-Marie Le Pen du passé le
Front National est un parti qui est
héritier qui a été créé par des gens qui
ont collaboré qui ont la responsabilité
morale de la Choa donc je m'excuse mais
le problème le problème il n'est pas
simplement de
propos antisémite de Jean-Marie
Lepen g que vous qualifz d'extrme on
rejo
de non non ne faites pas de la confusion
le rassemblement
national ben je vous dis je dis que vous
êtes faites du confusionnisme l'extrême
droiteent complotiste
non je sais pas ce que vous racontez
l'extrême droite est un parti qui a une
histoire qui s'ancre dans ce qui a été
l'antisémitisme qui a débouché sur la
Choa entre pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale donc ce n'est pas une petite
question de savoir si on défile avec le
rassemblement national ou pas donc je
comprend la difficulté et je pense
qu'elle devrait être celle de tous
d'avoir le rassemblement national dans
cette manifestation que ce soit les
partis de gauche qui
l'expriment je le comprends ça pourrait
être et j'imagine qu'ils ne sont pas les
seul à avoir cette difficulté j'imagine
que ça doit être le cas d'autres
militants citoyens conscients du
problème que cela pose ceci étant je je
crois que et et autre remarque aussi sur
ce que vous avez dit tout ne procède pas
de du désaccord je trouve très
déplorable la position qu'a pris
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et les dirigeants de
la France insoumise à propos du 7
octobre pas tous pas tous je viens de
dire les dirigeants et et et donc pas
tous comme vous précisez voilà tous mais
donc oui donc Jean-Luc Mélenchon et les
dirigeants qui sont autour de lui ont
pris une déposition déplorable ils ne
sont pas le le l'origine de la montée de
l'antisémitisme ça ne s'origine pas dans
cette affaire de du positionitionnement
est-ce que le Hamas est ou non mais
votre réaction sur le tweet Catherine
parce que là on parle quand même d'un
d'un appel de Gérard larchéb pivé a une
marche civique contre l'antisémitisme et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon dit les amis du
soutien inconditionnel au massacre ont
le rendez-vous je exactement je pense
que j'ai vu cette dernière phrase et je
la franchement elle ça me hérisse le
poil quoi je vraiment ça me fait ça me
fait frémir c'est-à-dire que quand on va
à cette manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme on soutient le les
massacres à Gaza mais non ce n'est pas
possible c'est là encore c'est faire un
amalgame et c'est se séparer se couper
de de tous ceux qui vont y participer et
de tous ceux qui considèrent aujourd'hui
qu'il y a une question sur laquelle il
faut que la République dans sa diversité
se lève donc je encore une fois jean-l
Mélenchon fait une stratégie du clivage
de clivage à l'intérieur de la gauche
une clivage à l'intérieur de la
République qui est enfin très
dommageable presque scandaleuse ouais
c'est c'est c'est ça peut être
dévastateur pour pour la gauche les
prises de position répété je mlchon je
vous dire il y a un double effet qui se
coule d'abord si vous regardez les
sondages voyez qu'aujourd'hui Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et la personne ité la plus
détestée politiquement dans ce pays tous
les sondages le montrent il perd 15 20
points enfin je crois même qu'il est
plus détesté que Éric Zemour dans
certains sondages puis deuxième chose il
faudrait qu'il s'interroge le leader
maximo Jean-Luc méenchon parce qu'en
fait il va avoir un socle fort mais il
pourra pas l'élargir en fait il va non
seulement sans doute il fait le Paris
inverse mais on verra d'être présent au
second tour et pourquoi pas de gagner
l'élection Pen mais surtout il va
empêcher la gauche
de gagner parce que non seulement il
fracture B oui s'il se maintient il fera
quand même son score donc il fracture
non seulement le pays là je suis
d'accord avec vous mais il fracture
également la gauche la gauche
républicaine les gauches irréconcidiable
comme l'a dit manuel Vals vous pensez
qu'elles vont voter pour Jean-Luc
mélenchan non on suivra évidemment tout
ça et cette marche dimanche donc à
l'appel de Gérard larchelle brun pivé on
regarde ensemble ce qui de nos quotidien
régionaux
[Musique]
et Steve à la une ce sont les chiffres
du harcèlement scolaire oui un jeune sur
C a déjà été victime de harcèlement
scolaire chiffre choc qui fait la Une de
l'Est Républicain étude réalisé par
l'Ifop alors que le gouvernement fait de
la lutte contre ce Filot une priorité ce
jeudi éisabeth be fera un déplacement
pour la journée de lutte contre le
harcèlement le slogan cette année est le
suivant ne pas minimiser ce que vivent
les enfants du jamais vu également oui
il faut parler des crues dans le Pas de
calis c'est ça c'est à la h de la voie
du Nord le département reste aujourd'hui
en vigilance orange après les cru
historique qui ont entraîné l'inondation
de plusieurs zones notamment autour de
Boulogne surmer et de Saint-Omer de gros
dégâts à signaler les images sont
impressionnantes elles sont à retrouver
dans la voie du Nord le journal se
penche aussi sur le rôle et la mission
délicate des équipes de secours et des
pompiers pourra-t-on choisir sa mort
c'est le débat qui se pose alors que le
gouvernement prépare une loi sur la fin
de vie Midi Libre consacre un dossier à
la question le journal donne la parole à
ceux qui ont accompagné un proche dans
cette décision difficile suicide assisté
euthanasie la société française va
devoir se prononcer alors que la
convention citoyenne a proposé il y a 6
mois de promouvoir une aide active à
mourir Midi Libre fait le point dans son
édition du jour et on finit par votre
nouvelle passion Steve la folie du
paddle le paddle vous savez ce que c'est
le paddle oui c'est une sorte de de
tennis voilà quatre joueurs deux équipes
de deux ça ressemble à du tennis mais ça
ne l'est pas ça ressemble à du squatch
mais ça ne l'est pas terrain plus petit
il y a des vitres autour et la la
montagne on le voit à sa Une se penche
sur un sport qui séduit la région de
Clermont les équipements se multiplient
dans le puit d'Ô il y a au total 400000
joueurs en France et l' verg n'est pas
épargné par le phénomène écrit le
journal le premier terrain a été ouvert
en 2016 et ces derniers mois les pistes
de paddle se multiplient partout dans la
région vous n donnerez des cours bah
bien sûr la Public Sénat on organisera
un tournoi de paddle padle la planche a
cl ah ouais mais ça c'est il y a pas
d'elle et pas d' bien le prononcer Éric
la Une de l'hémicycle oui la Une de
l'hémicycle donc la la revue qui aime la
politique avec une très longue interview
de Pierre moscovissi le président de la
la Cours des comptes voahilà qui dit
tout ce qu'il pense du projet de budget
la loi de finance de voilà et puis un
dossier très intéressant sur
intelligence artificielle et démocratie
et c'est àire dans l'hémicycle regard
c'est le climat absolument nous avons
fait un un travail assez solide pour
essayer de voir où on en est du point de
vue de la recherche scientifique les
vraies pistes et fausses pistes et pour
conclure que de toute façon on a besoin
de la science mais tout ne peut pas
reposer sur la science voilà lisez
regard lisez l'hémicycle merci beaucoup
et fait du padle padle merci beaucoup
Catherine tricot merci beaucoup et merci
Steve nous on se retrouve demain
prochain rendez-vous sur l'antenne à 15h
la séance de question d'actualité au
Gouvernement et puis à partir de 16h30
vous suivrez en direct l'examen du
projet de loi immigration très bonne
journée à
demain